Why? By chance...
When I was 9 years old, I lived next to the Cercle Tissier in Vincennes.
I had a friend who was doing Aikido brought me to the Cercle Tissier.
I sat on the edge of the tatami and watched a class
and I asked to be registered on the spot, twice per week.
It was unusual at the time because children usually practiced once a week.
I fell into it when I was little.
I started in 1989,
it's going to be my 30th year of practice, all of it at the Cercle Tissier.
I went to all the classes at the Cercle,
I did the children's classes, the teenagers classes, the adult classes, the weapons classes.
When I turned 17, I started the weapons classes so here it is.
It's been thirty years of practice with Christian and with his students who taught at the Cercle.
No, there aren't that many.
There are few who have such a long experience.
For instance, the children who started with me all stopped.
I don't know any who have continued
and unfortunately this is still the case from generation to generation, there are some who continue but not many...
What I notice though, is that people who started early
often end up becoming professionals, or teach classes,
or get invested in the discipline for a long time,
but there are few, it's true.
So, I'll start with the pros...
It's the largest European center for Aikido,
there are many people, there are many different levels,
there are many high level people of course,
there are many teachers there, so it's challenging from the get go.
There are beginners classes in Vincennes though,
which allows to have some scaffolding before getting to the big yard.
So that's a real opportunity to progress quickly
because you are with people who practice well,
with good teachers,
but the drawback is that you have to hang on because it's a bit hard,
the level is high, the pace of practice is fast...
Excellence is demanding so it takes a special king of people who are ready to commit to it.
It is true that people who come only for leisure
will have a little a harder time staying long in this particular club.
Yes and no because he tries to be present very regularly when he's not in teaching abroad,
which requires him to be absent in the week,
but he has a regularity of presence about which we can be honored and proud
because it is does that every week and it's not easy for him I think.
So he's still very, very present.
the chance we have is to have since ...
We're also lucky in that even though some teachers who have changed of course
but to have a regularity in the teachers who are there.
I think of Pascal, Bruno, Fabrice who have been here for years,
but we had other teachers too who were there for a long time
and who built the foundations...
That's the richness of this place, having Christian's teaching twice a week,
but supplemented by a number of teachers who are there to ensure...
At the time it was Pascal and Bruno who took care of the basics for Christian
so that he can do teach the more advanced material.
Today it has evolved a bit, that is to say that
each teacher having also gone up the ranks, each one does more of his personal work
so in that sense maybe there are fewer teachers who teach the basics
and a little bit more...
It may be a bit more diverse in the ways of teaching, maybe that's what has evolved.
But Christian's presence is just as important today compared to when I started.
In the atmosphere, yes, certainly.
I have to put that in context: When I started going to adult classes, I was 14
I was with my brown belt and my hakama,
the first 3 years, until I got my black belt were very very difficult
because the teaching was perhaps harder, more physical
physical in the sense a little "rough"
so I got hurt quite a bit.
The protocol was perhaps much stricter too.
It was a little harder overall.
The relationships between people were hard too
Today the relationships are technical, tonic, physical,
but perhaps more benevolent.
People are a bit more caring with each other,
men towards women, women towards each other...
I have known a time when women were hard with each other,
women were tough with men, men...
It was a hard environment overall.
In terms of physical relationships but even more so in terms of human relationships
and that was the hardest thing.
Today, of course I don't have the same level, nor the same experience,
we should ask people who start nowadays...
I think it's still hard for them
but it's hard because the technical level and the expectations are high.
I think that it's in the relations between people that it has evolved in a good way.
This is not only my opinion, I heard it from several generations of practitioners
and female practitioners especially.
I think it has evolved...
It's still as intense
but more caring,
I would say more caring.
The technical coherence is still there, of course,
because the people who teach at the Cercle are students of Christian
so there is a definite consistency,
but those are people who have evolved in their practice
so they don't teach now in the same way as they taught before.
Obviously Christian's teaching has evolved as well.
But...
There might have been more of a direct connection in the classes we did Monday to Friday,
because I was doing all the classes of the Cercle.
There was maybe more of a systematic repetition,
suwari, hanmi handachi, tachi waza...
I remember classes with Bruno where we did a lot of suwari waza and hanmi handachi waza,
which really gave us the keys to practice afterwards in tachi waza.
Maybe today they all teach a little less on their knees so maybe we do less of it.
They don't have the same level either, so they don't teach the same things.
So it's possible that the discourse is now more geared towards people who have already learned the basics elsewhere.
Perhaps they're less lost.
While before, it was perhaps easier to catch up.
That's a feeling that I have.
GE: Because in terms of staff it's the same people?
It's roughly the same people, Pascal, Bruno, Fabrice, and Patrick as well.
Patrick Benezzi has been teaching for a long time.
Philippe Orban also taught, but he's no longer there now,
Daniel Bourguignon who was teaching the Friday night class, who's no longer there now,
Philippe Bersani who taught weapons classes, who's not either ...
Some teachers have come and gone, but...
Marc Bachraty also taught at the Cercle,
but for people who've been practicing for a long time,
we've had the same teachers for 15 - 20 years yes, it didn't change...
Teachers have moved in their teaching and in their practice, of course, but...
When I met Pascal, he must have been 2nd or 3rd dan, now he is 6th dan,
same for Bruno,
so obviously it's not the same context
and perhaps today the teachers allow themselves a more personal research.
Ah it's hard to evaluate...
The economic circumstances have changed a little too.
I think there are fewer people who can afford, economically or in terms of time,
to do all the classes of the Cercle, there are was fewer than before.
There are also fewer visitors from abroad than before,
I remember people coming from Poland, Germany,
who stayed months and months sleeping at the dojo,
it's still less frequent.
More people do round-trips, but fewer spend several months in the dojo, for sure.
I think it's more to do with economic circumstances than anything else.
I terms of people from the Cercle,
it's a bit more difficult to evaluate because there are people who come at lunchtime,
and others come in the evenings.
It's not like it's two different clubs, but there's a bit of that.
Many teachers come at noon because for us it's convenient,
we have our classes at night, so we come to train during lunchtime,
and the people who come more as a hobby come after work.
I think there's still a large number of people who are form the Cercle Tissier,
but in terms of people who take all the classes,
I think it's about 20 people at most.
People who do all the classes, all the seminars, and who also train outside the dojo, wherever Christian goes.
It's probably about 20 peoples our of the while lot.
The number a the Cercle Tissier is much more important than that.
No, as Christian says, I am a pure product of Vincennes.
I didn't spread myself.
Having started as a child, the logic was to do everything that Christian did, so I followed him in seminars a lot.
I also followed Pascal Guillemin a lot,
Bruno's seminars, a little less,
but it was the norm to follow the deshi in their seminars.
So for my training, I mostly did the classes at the Cercle,
and seminars with Christian.
Unlike many moms, it's when I got my first boy
that I switched to completely to doing Aikido,
because Fabrice doing the same thing,
we had a symmetry in our schedules that allowed us to take care of our children
a lot during the day since we work during lunchtimes, evenings, and weekends,
so we can really take care of the all the rest of the time.
I worked a lot before in the industry of the games and the toys
I liked it a lot, I worked in game libraries, toy stores, game events,
that's something that speaks to me and that is important to me,
but, as I went along, I had more and more responsibilities, classes, seminars to teach,
and when I gave birth to my first child...
I never really decided it but it was in the logic of things to switch completely,
like Fabrice, as an aikido professional to harmonize our schedules
and take care of our children.
Yes, Fabrice has his dojo in Montreuil, in the suburbs, where I teach children's classes,
and I opened a dojo ten ago years in the south of Paris,
near the Place d'Italie where I started ...
it's a municipal dojo, so I started with two students and after ten years,
I am very happy because we are more than 100 adults.
So it's a dojo that's starting to run well.
Some have been there since the beginning
but because of my curriculum, a lot of people also come from outside.
In the past few years, the dojo got more populated,
with people who are 4th dan, or 5th dan sometimes,
who come to follow my teaching in addition to what they do in their own dojo.
I have teachers who come too, so it gives density
and of course additional responsibilities to the teaching,
but after 10 years
there is a part of the groundwork of the dojo that's been established, and it's very pleasing.
For now, I'm trying to really stay present...
The dojo is still too recent,
I haven't trained people yet who are able to substitute for me, with the adequate credentials.
People still have to move up the ranks and get diplomas.
So I'm always present for my classes,
but it's true that I have more and more seminars to give on weekends,
I have a little over twenty seminars to teach,
in the future it will be the real challenge to be attentive to both.
But it's true that it's starting now, since I've been appointed this year as director...
-- No, what is it called now? It'S not called DTR... --
I'm Regional Technical Referent for Normandy,
following the reform of the Technical College of our Federation,
so I'm going to have extra responsibilities
so more obligations and more seminars...
I also have a few seminars abroad which are becoming regular,
so it's creating interesting new opportunities,
but it will take a little rigor to be able to run things seriously,
and so that no one is left out.
It seems important to me that the people of the dojo...
don't feel "abandoned" because it is still the foundation of the practice,
for a teacher,
in my opinion it's his dojo that's the most important,
the people he trains, how he teaches, who will keep practicing in future...
Seminars are great, it's very good to promote one's practice, but the base is the dojo.
I believe that what keeps the desire for practice
is simply the joy of being on a tatami...
The joy of doing the movements, of being kneaded, of kneading others,
it's simple things, really, I think we shouldn't look ...
In my case, I'm not looking for what isn't there.
It's a simple pleasure,
and consequently, it's easy enough to get back to it.
We don't ask too many questions
even if, obviously, there are moments when it's more difficult than others to step on the tatami.
It's not that we get demotivated, but we can have pain everywhere, we can be less inspired,
it's important to take breaks from time to time as well,
to keep moments without Aikido, to renew one's inspiration, I think...
It brings me a lot of serenity I think.
It's the right word, a lot of stability...
Since Fabrice is doing the same thing, I think we agree a lot, we listen to each other a lot, we support each other a lot,
I think it's very important for us too to be two in the practice.
I think I wouldn't have the same profile if I was a practitioner and my companion wasn't.
We often talk about it with people who are in this situation,
they are the only one practicing, it is not always easy to share
the joys and the sorrows of the tatami, the responsibilities,
Fabrice also has responsibilities, he is DFR of Guyana from this season,
so he too is made to travel a lot.
So we have the same kind of journey and evolution in our journey,
so it allows us to share and stay grounded,
not to go into considerations...
Have ideas...
Staying open, staying simple,
not to think that if we have seminars, more classes, e more students...
Stay humble.
I think it helps to be two also on that, it grounds you.
Yes, it helps a lot for putting things into perspective, especially things that don't go well.
If tomorrow we're no longer Director of a region
or if we have a period when we get less seminars,
or we aren't asked to participate to an event,
it means it was not our job to do it,
or that it wasn't the right time.
I try to stay honest and simple in our practice
without a second thought.
I think that's what characterizes us both,
I speak for Fabrice, but that's the way we see things.
We aren't complicated people.
We like the practice, we like people, we like what we do.
We try to get on with it and to always have joy and envy, simply.
I think there never was.
In 20 years that we are together,
there never was any competition at all.
I consider Fabrice as my sempai
because he was more senior than me already when I arrived so as teenager,
he was already 1st dan or 2nd, I don't remember,
so for me he was already a model.
I asked him to help me prepare for my 1st dan,
shy, timidly, so that was the beginning of our relationship
but I always had Fabrice as a reference.
I took his classes in Vincennes, I went to his seminars,
I continue to go with pleasure.
Nothing makes me more happy than to do an seminar with Fabrice
so I think there was never any idea of ​​competition between us.
There was already enough of it around us,
or from other people towards us, without us wanting it,
for us to want to put competition in our relationship and as aikidoka.
We've been able to work thewe things out pretty quickly.
When we're both practitioners, we have a relationship as practitioners,
when he is a teacher, I am a student,
We know how to work those things things out,
but in terms of competition,
it never happened,
for neither of us.
Yes it is not trivial because since for us it has been hard when we arrived,
we really didn't want it to happen again for the maximum of people
with whom we were in contact.
That's something that we did deliberately.
We've always worked to try to welcome people,
-- within the limits of our possibilities because we are not omnipresent --
but when we practiced a lot and every day, it was easier of course,
we still have 2 lunchtime classes per week with Christian, we try to continue doing it but
if it's not in Vincennes, it'll be during seminars or other occasions,
any event where we meet people,
we always try facilitate relationships
without allowing ourselves to be overwhelmed, that's the risk since we are pretty open people.
Within reason, we try to keep friendly relations with people,
but to remain mainly facilitators so that there is a good energy that circulates.
On our small scale, if we can contribute to it,
it's really something we've tried to do, for years actually.
So...
I always have in mind what Christian said,
he often tells us that he didn't learn how to do suwari-waza,
he was doing shikko, with no indication, no "technique",
so that's why the've damaged their knees a lot...
When we talk with many elders, they tell us:
"We went for it, but we didn't think too much."
Experienced practitioners have often told me that our generations,
are just as physical but also more technical.
So, there is wear and tear, of course, but probably less.
Perhaps we have gained in terms of precision and advice given to students.
In my classes, I always do suwari and hanmi handachi.
I was never taught much how to
how to place the ankles, how to orientate the knees, how to place the hips,
we walked, and that was it.
But I try to give them more precise indications.
Also for front and back falls.
As for me, I just fell. I was not told: "You put your hand like this", "You do like this",
whereas today, yes, I will be much more a pedagogical
on all things to do upstream of the practice,
how to place yourself to fall, start at different levels, maybe on the ground before getting up...
I continue to do it because it's part of my heritage so
I transmit it of course, but with perhaps more instructions and...
safety, for the body, to be able to do it longer.
I hope that it works, we'll talk about it in 20 years, I don't know, maybe I'll have knee pain too.
So perhaps a little more pedagogy and instruction,
maybe it helps to last longer.
I'm often told...
I do not have the internal sensation, but I'm often told that I have an aikido that is clear and clean.
That it's easy to read, easy to reproduce.
It seems difficult to be able to do the same movement four times.
Bruno Gonzalez who told us:
"If you can do the same movement four times without changing any detail,"
"it means that you are able to anchor things in a very structured way."
I kept that in mind and I'm trying to do it,
up to a certain limit, that it doesn't stiffen the body.
The work I'm trying to do is not to break free from the form but it's
to try things out more.
I tell my students to allow themselves to make rough drafts,
to do things that are not beautiful, to do things that are not satisfactory for them,
things a little more direct,
to avoid being in something too polished.
The extreme counterpart of being clear and clean is maybe to be a bit too smooth.
That's what I say to myself.
Perhaps doing things more lively, more natural, more spontaneous,
maybe that's my research for the moment.
I don't have a preconceived idea...
I don't police myself, I do what I like to do.
Often, if it is a private seminar, I do what I like to do in my dojo at that particular time,
explore a sensation, explore placements,
explore various things that interest me when I do it in my dojo.
I don't have a set idea because it's going to be different, because I'm a woman.
-- I don't want to talk about men's aikido and women's aikido, --
but as a female teacher, necessarily it will be different, presented differently, experienced differently.
I try to practice with people, it's really something that I like to do,
to make me feel.
I get a lot of inspiration from what Yoko Okamoto does
because it's someone I admire a lot and I like a lot and she does it a lot in her seminars.
She goes with people, she gives a lot of herself, she really conveys it with her body.
I answered an interview not long ago where I said:
"It's true that when I go to meet people during seminars, I try to convince them with my body"
"and not by my speech."
In the end,
in this kind of martial discipline,
our peer recognize us because we convince them physically.
That's the way I see it.
I try to teach by making them feel what I'm doing. That's my idea.
It's complementary to practice, that is to say that I had mostly men teacher.
They were all benevolent, very structuring, and treated me equally,
there was neither positive discrimination nor exclusion at all -- on the part of the teachers at least --.
So I didn't feel any difference in the way I was treated.
So I can say that it would have been just the same, whether I had male or female teachers.
Even so, it's still an easier access door, for a female practitioner,
to have a female referent at the start because it may be more reassuring.
Perhaps the first step will be a bit more difficult,
-- maybe, --
if it's a referent man at the start.
I refer a lot to the classes I give at the university
because I have classes for college students,
and it turns out that Aikido,
I'm in the martial arts section and I'm the only female teacher.
Last year I had 73 people enrolled
and an overwhelming majority of girls.
So I think that for a beginner, it's a little easier
if at the beginning, they have some female referents, to be able to have options.
After that it's okay.
With the diversity of practice and teaching evens it all.
It's not essential.
That's why, again, that I don't insist on whether teachers are male or female,
they're just teachers.
Perhaps as a first access door, yes, it's easier, maybe.
Maybe yes, with the efforts that are made on all sides, as you said.
On the part of the State, on the part of politicians in general, on the part of the IAF...
Things are changing, the lines move so maybe it creates openings.
Women may realize that they have more opportunities than they thought.
There are many factors.
When I was pregnant,
I continued to practice, in a very careful way, and especially to teach until the end of my pregnancies.
Then the Federation contacted me saying: "Yes, it's true, we hadn't thought of that,"
"but yes, there is a definite possibility that ..."
So I was asked to share my experience to see how far women could remain integrated in the dojos when they were pregnant.
It was not limiting, it was not contraindicated,
if precautions were taken.
So I think the lines are moving and maybe in the future,
we are at the beginning, but there will be more ...
opportunities for women to feel
able, invited, given room, to engage more in practice,
more over the long term, without breaks in practice, yes.
I think there is a bit of both, I think there is still some reluctance, let's face it.
There are both possibilities, that is to say,
they're not given much space because traditionally there is no need for it,
or they're given limited space, during children classes, or limited responsibilities on lower tasks...
On the other hand, there are others...
There is a clash of generations we're on a transition.
There are people who really want
to change things, to bring out a real diversity,
and then there are still pockets of resistance yes, of course.
We haven't finished the transition.
It's normal that, in fact, there are still not many high-ranking women yet.
We were discussing with Vilko Vriesman,
about the fact that there will be a generation gap while things change.
Below my generation, there will be a gap,
and then, the base will be reformed.
At the moment, we're lacking young females between 20 and 30 who could take over.
Perhaps right now, those females don't yet see that there is a future for them.
It's a hard question indeed ...
I think there are a lot of young people, 18-25 years old,
who are potentially interested in Aikido because that just gives them a way to
to let off steam, to work out, but without competition
because that, really, is something that weighs on them
in their studies, in the pressures for the job after, they have a multitude of things that accumulate.
Here they have a discipline that offers them just to free themselves without having any ulterior motive,
or objective, so that, I think that's a real argument in our favor.
It sets us apart from judo and Karate
because it's perhaps a little less rough,
which comes from the fact that there is not real combat,
but we need to present things well, because they aren't going to buy into anything.
Perhaps before, we could just be a teacher and students would come to us,
but today's teachers must go a little more out to get the students.
We need to diversify the public and go get the youngsters where they are.
to tell them: "Aikido is good and it will do you good"
"you'll be able to work out and sweat".
In fact, they're looking for an Aikido that is dynamic.
An Aikido that is too intellectual would bore them.
Some of my students also study science, or other technical things,
so they don't want to get into something else really intellectual, they want to let off some steam,
within a framework that suits them, because Aikido is very ritualized and technical.
Perhaps we have a profile of practitioners...
Generally, statistical studies on the profile of Aikdio practitioners show that
it doesn't cover all of the socio-professional categories.
It's a fact.
So we have to go and get the youths
because French youths like Japanese culture,
manga, culture, everything...
and the desire to let stem off and free themselves while learning a martial art.
There might also be an aspect of self-defense,
self-confidence, control over one's emotions...
there are many fields in which we have a  public for the next generation.
It's true that the arguments that we used to present,
as something very traditional,
a conception that might have fitted the 70's and 80's,
can't be used at all anymore.
But once again, the youths are really into it.
As an example, they think it's fantastic when a character does Aikido in a show like "The Walking Dead",
or when they find a character that does Aikido in a Japanese series,
In "La Casa de Papel", they have an episode in the 3rd season that talks about Aikido,
it goes viral on social networks before it talks about Aikido for 2 minutes,
those are signs that Aikido has a good image
and we need to make use of it.
Whether people are practitioners or not, it interest them that we speak about Aikido in their favorite series.
We need to find a way to communicate that is a little more modern.
A bit more tangible and pragmatic.
We often say that Aikido is a big family.
It's true!
I did volleyball, swimming, and other sport activities,
-- apart from competition, that I'll set aside because I didn't like it at all --
there is a structuring of the Aikido system
that seemed very constructive to me as a teenager, even though I couldn't explain it.
Today I can put words on it but back then, it was an intuition,.
I had the feeling that my seniors and sempai, close to me,
people who were below me, and my teachers, all formed a whole.
We were going something together, and that was going to be great.
It's something really structuring and reassuring.
In terms of the richness of relationships between people,
in terms of relationships that run over 10 or 20 years of interactions,
it may be unique...
Out of all the sports activities that I did, that is the most unique thing.
Often, practitioners come...
They come for practice of course, but also for social link that it creates.
For the family that they may not have and a number of other reasons.
I can see now I'm here,
there are some people I know, others that I don't,
there is a sort of emulsion that take place, we take part in the same activities,
we get the feeling to be working on something that is larger than us,
that puts us in the same family beyond frontiers.
It's quite exceptional in Aikido.
We're doing the rehearsals for the demonstration that is going to take place tomorrow for this event in Iwama.
There will be three parts, and I get to go last.
There will be one part for basic techniques, one for Iwama-style weapons,
en then a free practice part.
The most time-consuming thing is to work out the etiquette, the bow,
so that everybody is synchronized.
It's not so much for etiquette itself, but so that it looks correct.
This is often what takes the most time during demonstrations,
but not much more than during the usual demonstrations.
It's always like that, we have an intense effort to provide in a short time.
We have to give our best, like in all demonstrations, often without any warm-up.
It's part of the game, as usual.
For people from the IAF, it's a great honor to participate in this,
and it allows to create connections between people on an international level,
and to realize that we're a great family,
and that we participate in something that is larger than us.
We don't always get all the inns and outs of it,
but here, it's a very concrete event so that's very important.